[Music]
the day I was going to sign my papers to
start working there were 3,000 inmates
out there working iron and I was like
what did I get myself into here my name
is karma Shaheen I'm the career
technical and educator for cosmetology
at Valley State Prison Foreman when I
tell people that I work teaching
cosmetology and a men's prison a lot of
people are shocked by it they're
surprised they didn't even think that it
was available this program takes
approximately two years and they have to
have 1,600 hours completed in order to
take the State Board Exam there is a
waiting list to get into this class and
in order to get into this class an
inmate has to meet certain behavioral at
educational um standards why you come
into my classroom you're gonna treat
each other with respect and common
courtesy and there's no boundaries in
here which is gonna relax your facial
muscles and improve your blood flow
throughout your face my name is Juan
Ruiz Walla I'm here at Valley State
Prison in Chowchilla California my
favorite part of the class is the skin
care part of it which includes like the
face shows eyebrows makeup I like to to
see my clients relaxed
get comfortable with me with its real
personal and being imprisoned a teacher
not to touch each other not to touch
staff it goes against the norm of what
people see about prison on TV you know
ex-gang members come in with tattoos on
their face all over their body is not
something that you see out there working
in a beauty salon it's putting a line on
a different side of the prison system I
do treat them as here with me and I'm
not here to punish them I'm just here to
show them a skill that I have and it
happens to be in a prison I have more
empathy for people now because of doing
this type of work when they get their
license it's like I've gotten my license
for the first time all over again it's
very rewarding
[Music]